guten morgen wir von der woche melden
uns heute vom frankfurter
weihnachtsmarkt eigentlich moderieren
das ganze hier her maja brankovic und
andreas nefzger heute muss ich ran warum
weiß ich auch nicht ich will das
eigentlich aber ich soll ihrem gewissen
leiten und das haben mit unserer ausgabe
zu tun wir blicken nämlich aus jahr 2019
zurück und jetzt haben wir uns überlegt
stellen wir doch meier brankovic und
andreas nefzger mal ein paar fragen
wieso das jahr 2009 10 war
und da kommt der weihnachtsmarkt und
spielt der der verliert der muss nämlich
mit diesem karussell dort fahren und ich
habe gehört dass es für erwachsene total
uncool
[Musik]
so legen wir los suchen uns mal ein
glühweinstand und dann ab mit kommt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
kommen wir zu den regeln ich stellbrink
von andreas nefzger jetzt zehn fragen
wer die antwort weiß drückt den basar
und gibt die antwort ist die antwort
falsch steckt ein minuspunkt ist die
antwort richtet ein pluspunkt am ende am
meisten punkte hat gewonnen und muss
nicht karussellfahrt seid ihr bereit für
frage 1 im mai sind die deutschen
aufgerufen das europaparlament zu wählen
die jungen nutzen die wahl um die
bundesregierung absicht haben die frage
dazu
vor der wahl hatte ein youtuber zur
zerstörung erzählt torsten friese
vielleicht hast du leider falsch ich
lese mal die frage weiter wurde rieso
1999 geboren in wuppertal
kommen wir zur nächsten frage 1 0 für
mayer christine lagarde wird am ersten
november präsidentin der europäischen
zentralbank in welches land zog lagarde
im alter von 18 jahren in die
vereinigten staaten
das ist richtig wie heißen die
landeshauptstädter dieser länder
potsdam dresden und erfurt das richtig
21 frage nummer vier
und da können wir nur zum die spd die
mal wieder absolut im juni tritt andrea
nahles als spd vorsitzender zurück und
jetzt eine schätzfrage wer näher dran
ist gewinnt wie lange war sie im arm
13 monate und 13 tage
[Musik]
15 monate 13 monate ist richtig punkt
für andreas 22
[Musik]
also wir haben die hälfte unserer fragen
hinter uns und es läuft so lala
ich hätte gedacht man weiß mehr wenn man
die woche liest also man muss mehr
wissen wenn man die woche wirklich gut
liest dann steht jetzt 3 zu 3 wobei die
letzten beiden punkte eigentlich looser
punkte waren
[Musik]
die nächste frage beschäftigt sich mit
der afd die wurde im januar vom
verfassungsschutz zum prüfen erklärt und
ich suche jetzt vier verschiedene leute
wer hat es gesagt wer zuerst zwei
richtige hat gewonnen begriff nummer
eins messer einwanderung
ich glaube beatrix von storch
ich glaube alles beide begriffe nummer
zwei nur ein vogel schießt ja messer
einwanderung war ja auch zu schwer
nummer drei die moscheen müssen vom
verfassungsschutz überwacht und
gegebenenfalls beatrix von storch
wichtig damit kommen wir jetzt zum
letzten satz der entscheidet politik der
wohltemperierten grausamkeit korrekt
punkte andreas
welcher politiker der zuvor
verteidigungsminister war schaffte es
später bundeskanzler zu werden
helmut schmidt ja wohl alles läuft
gerade gut für andreas schlecht für maja
5 zu 3 mal was seine taktik was wird zu
machen damit es besser läuft
vielleicht meinen pass hat das war eine
gute idee
frage nummer acht beschäftigt sich mit
dem duell am golf im mai ereignet sich
im persischen golf sabotageakte an
handelsschiffen wie heißt eigentlich das
wichtigste nadelöhr der weltwirtschaft
es tut mir leid ich glaube du wirst raus
die straße von hormus ist die richtige
antwort
[Musik]
du musst covers altmaier
andreas wir für zu dick das monatelange
vorbereitung hat sich ausbezahlt ich bin
wirklich sehr glücklich
ja man hat gemerkt dass du dich auch
alles gut ja also ich bin stolz auf euch
beide dann los
[Musik]
naja wie gehts ja sehr gut ich bin seit
20 jahren keinen karussell mehr gefahren
träumst reform eine niederlage und über
kleine runde
viel spaß
[Musik]
so dass bass von der woche für dieses
jahr wir melden uns wieder im neuen jahr
ich wünsche euch ein frohes fest einen
guten rutsch ins neue jahr
und auch so wenn ihr kein noch kein
geschenk für weihnachten die woche aber
kann man nicht einmal leisten irgendwie
hallo viel spaß
[Musik]